>> Tammy: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING ME.
REMEMBER WHEN PROTESTERS WENT TO
MITCH McCONNELL'S HOUSE
CALLING FOR HIM TO BE MURDERED
AND BROADCASTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA?
>> SOME VOODOO DOLLS [BLEEP].
>> THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT IT IS.
JUST STABBED THE [BLEEP] IN THE
HEART.
>> Tammy: THE McCONNELL
CAMPAIGNS TWITTER ACCOUNT POSTED
THE VIDEO EXPOSING THE THREATS.
AND THEN THE ACCOUNT WAS
PROMPTLY FROZEN FOR VIOLATING
TWITTER RULES.
MEANWHILE, THE HASHTAG
#MassacreMitch WAS ALLOWED TO
TREND.
THE RNC AND TRUMP CAMPAIGN SAY
THEY WON'T BE SPENDING MORE
MONEY ON TWITTER FOR THE TIME
BEING.
HERE TO DISCUSS IT AND FOR A
LITTLE BIT OF A DEBATE AS
CHARLIE HURT, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF TURNING POINT USA.
THE REVEREND SHANE HARRIS,
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST AND
PRESIDENT OF THE PEOPLE'S
ALLIANCE FOR JUSTICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
ME.
I APPRECIATE IT.
CHARLIE, WE JUST TALKED TO
FLECCAS.
HE'S EXPERIENCE SOME
DEMONIZATION ON YOUTUBE.
WE HAVE THE EXTRAORDINARY
ABSURDITY OF SOMEBODY'S
ACCOUNTING FROZEN BECAUSE THEY
EXPOSE THREATS AGAINST
THEMSELVES.
I NOW OF COURSE WE KNOW OF
COURSE ALL THE CONSERVATIVES
WHO'VE BEEN BLOCKED AND
SUSPENDED AND REMOVED FROM THE
MEDIUM.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT THEY'VE
BECOME SO BOLD IN THE MIDST OF
THIS CONSIDERING THE PRESIDENTS
ALSO SPOKEN OUT AGAINST IT?
AND YET YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THIS
IS A REMARKABLY BOLD THING TO DO
ON THEIR END.
>> UNBELIEVABLY BOLD.
AS THE SEGMENT HAPPENS,
MITCH McCONNELL TWITTER
ACCOUNT IS FROZEN.
YET HAMAS, WHO USES CHILDREN AS
HUMAN SHIELDS, HAS A TWITTER
ACCOUNT.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THE MORAL IN EQUIVALENCY IS THAT
SENATOR MITCH McCONNELL HAS A
TWITTER ACCOUNT FROZEN FOR
SHARING A VIDEO.
HE DIDN'T ENDORSE IT.
HE DIDN'T SAY IT.
SUPPORTERS DIDN'T SAY IT.
HE WAS SHOWING A VIDEO OF WHAT
OTHER PEOPLE WERE SAYING ABOUT
HIM, THAT THEY WANTED HIM DEAD
AND HE WAS SAYING LOOK AT    ATH
AND HE WAS SAYING LOOK AT    ATE
RADICALISM.
TWITTER LOCKED DOWN THE ACCOUNT.
HAMAS WHO USES CHILDREN AS HUMAN
SHIELDS HAS A TWITTER ACCOUNT
RIGHT NOW.
SOMETHING'S GOT TO CHANGE WITH
THESE TECH OLIGARCHS.
>> Tammy: THE PRESIDENT HAS
INTIMATED THAT HE MAY DO
SOMETHING.
BY EXECUTIVE ORDER?
WERE NOT SURE WHAT THAT WOULD
BE.
SHANE, I THINK WHETHER YOU AGREE
WITH MITCH McCONNELL OR
DISAGREE, YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THAT
HAVING MASSACRE MITCH TRENDING
AND TO BLOCK THE
MITCH McCONNELL CAMPAIGN
ACCOUNT IS A LITTLE STRANGE.
WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> I WOULD AGREE THAT THE
BACKLASH TO WHAT IS BEING
DISCUSSED WITH
SENATOR McCONNELL, WHAT
EXACTLY HIS CAMPAIGN WAS TRYING
TO SHARE, THAT BACKLASH I THINK
IS A LITTLE UNFAIR.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY, HERE'S A
REALITY.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY, MANY, MUCH
RADICALIZATION GOING ON ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
WHILE THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ON THE RIGHT ABOUT
CONSERVATIVES BEING SHUT DOWN ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, THERE'S ALSO MANY
OTHER FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN SHUT
DOWN WHO ARE NOT BEING
DISCUSSED.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO BE FAIR.
>> Tammy: I DON'T DOUBT IT.
>> WE HAVE TO BE FAIR ACROSS THE
LINE WHEN WERE TALKING ABOUT --
>> Tammy: YES, BUT HERE'S WHY
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT.
THE McCONNELL CAMPAIGN WAS
EXPOSING HOW EXTREME THINGS HAVE
BECOME.
I AM A FORMER COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER.
MAYBE I STILL AM, TO A DEGREE.
I THINK ORGANIZING IS IMPORTANT
AND I THINK DEMONSTRATIONS ARE
IMPORTANT.
THIS IS NOT THAT.
THEY WERE EXPOSING WHAT IT'S
BECOME.
CHARLIE, THIS IS WHAT IS SO
FASCINATING.
THIS SHOULD FIT RIGHT WITHIN OUR
GOALS TO RECOGNIZE THIS, FOR
AMERICANS TO BE SHOCKED AND THEN
TO STOP IT.
CHARLIE.
>> I'M GOING TO COMPLETELY
INVALIDATE THE PREVIOUS POINT,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
THIS IS TARGETING CONSERVATIVES
AND REPUBLICANS.
WE LOOK AT THE DISCREPANCY OF
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTION THAT
GOOGLE.
$0 DONATED TO DONALD TRUMP THE
2016 ELECTION, OVER $20 MILLION
GIVEN TO HILLARY CLINTON.
THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW THE BUYS
IS ONLY -- AND EQUALLY SPREAD
OUT IS JUST NOT TRUE.
YOU ARE TRYING TO TELL ME THAT
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER, IF
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER HAD A
VIDEO OF CONSERVATIVE SHOWING UP
TO HIS HOUSE WISHING DEATH TO
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER, YOU THINK
IF SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER SHOWED
THAT VIDEO THAT TWITTER WOULD
SHUT HIM DOWN?
>> WAIT A MINUTE, CHARLIE.
>> THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
>> WE CAN HAVE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS BUT WE CAN HAVE
DIFFERENT FACTS.
CHARLIE.
[ALL SPEAKING]
YOU ARE WRONG BECAUSE GOOGLE
PACS HAVE GIVEN THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO REPUBLICANS IN
CAMPAIGNS.
>> $0 TO DONALD TRUMP.
>> THE ACTION COMMITTEE HAS
GIVEN MORE MONEY IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS TO REPUBLICANS,
FEDERAL CANDIDATES.
>> THE GOOGLE EXECUTIVES.
>> WE CAN HAVE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS BUT LET'S TALK FACTS.
>> APOLOGIZE TO THEIR EMPLOYEES
AFTER THE ELECTION SAYING WE
WILL NEVER LET THIS HAPPEN
AGAIN.
IF YOU THINK GOOGLE AND
SILICON VALLEY ARE TILTING TO
THE RIGHT, YOUR COMPASS IS
UPSIDE DOWN.
THEY ARE A WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> GIVING MORE MONEY TO
REPUBLICAN FEDERAL CANDIDATES
THAN DEMOCRAT FEDERAL CANDIDATE
CANDIDATES.
PUT YOUR MONEY WHERE YOUR MOUTH
IS.
>> Tammy: JUST A MINUTE.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY WHERE THE
MONEY'S GONE.
IT'S WHAT PEOPLE END UP DOING
AND ALSO CONSIDER BOTH OF YOU
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT, I
KNOW CHARLIE, YOU ARE, WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
THAT THEY MIGHT BE GETTING MONEY
FROM GOOGLE BECAUSE THEY AGREE
WITH SHUTTING DOWN CERTAIN KINDS
OF INDIVIDUALS.
ALL OF US LOSE WHO HAVE AN
INTEREST IN HAVING RADICAL OR
NONCONFORMING VOICES TO BE HEAR
HEARD.